[Laughter]
that was perfect
that's a perfect episode no i'm just
crying
what's going on reject nation we're
going to watch brooklyn
99 episode 10 today just to catch up on
this little copyright claim partial
block journey
right now as a film in this only episode
seven is partially blocked here's hoping
this one goes okay
you know i think the department in
brooklyn nine-nine does such a fine job
because they have quality coffee
okay are you telling me this because
you constantly smell like coffee no i'm
telling you this because it's important
not to settle for mediocre coffee when
you could have today's video sponsored
deliver it right to your door at rosary
peak freshness
and shut up it's a condition
transition big thanks to trade coffee
for sponsoring this video
john why don't you go ahead and tell
them a trade coffee is all about what
makes it so great yeah i'm getting there
would you give me a second could you
trade helps you discover new coffees
from local roasters across the nation
and then matches you with your own
personal selection roasted and shipped
in compostable packaging within 24 hours
of your order
what does compostable mean you don't
know what you're so stupid
why don't you just ask me how to get
started
why are you being so mean how to get
started greg asks well let me tell you
to start you'll head to trade's website
take the quiz to establish your taste
and experience then you'll choose your
delivery schedule and finally
rate the coffee you're matched with so
trade can keep you stocked with roasts
that you'll
love wow really sounds like trade would
help save you a trip to the grocery
store
oh wow bravo greg you remember the
talking point
seriously you're like starting to hurt
my feelings they have a first match
guarantee which basically says you'll
love your first bag or they'll send you
a new one totally free
out of the three roast trade centers i
started with this one from
doma coffee roasting company it's their
carmella's blend it's got notes of brown
sugar which i definitely picked up with
my own tongue
i will not be returning this so good job
trade wow sounds like
boyle would really love boyle would
really love this yeah so i saw that joke
coming a mile away too
dang you know i sure liked it you know
trade me out ha ha you know what makes
comedy work greg is when you're not so
dang predictable all the time so if
you're interested in trying some new and
delicious coffee the first 100 people to
head on down to that description box use
our special link and enter code real
rejects
50 will receive 50 off in their first
bag upon sign up plus free
shipping that sounds awesome but you
know can i finally try some of that
coffee you're the one who smells
[Music]
what what's going on we're playing boyle
bingo thanksgiving edition
everyone filled out their cards with
possible charles related scenarios first
bingo gets a hundred bucks boyle says
gobble gobble gobble well now that i
know you want me to say that i'll just
say it with two gobbles
no gobble god it just it just sounds
right that way
i don't like this game boyle objects to
boil bingo
oh no oh i feel you boyle
sitting over here quietly all day and
doing nothing
anybody have boiled falls on the floor
no one that's a victory for boyle
boom boy
[Music]
i feel for you boyle you be boyle
absolutely everyone has a john
bingo card i'd be andre brower
yeah absolutely
first character i think of i was doing a
bust
cocaine thanks lucious
cow okay whole thing turned into an
awesome car chase
it's me johnny law that's
really well done jump up that shutter
speed
the whole holiday is based on overeating
we should be wearing velvet track suits
and diapers
jacket and ty rosa's even wearing her
formal leather jacket
it's one without any blood on it and
you're gonna give a toast about what
you're thankful for start preparing
oh i prefer not to prepare for my toast
i just wing them like scat jazz
scoop it up at that basket the door
couldn't shut because of your empty
pizza box
pizza please this is a butternut squash
and truffle butter flatbread
my lunch is ruined my chicken my
potatoes
my pasta meatballs
so this is your lunch for like the month
i need to eat 10 000 calories a day to
maintain muscle mass
my wife made me all of this before she
left town with the kids that was
everything in my fridge
well boyle can duplicate it absolutely
so i just wanted to make sure that you
knew about the thanksgiving dinner i'm
hosting for the squad after work
yes i received your save the date
decorative gourd
and this beautiful handcrafted card of a
turkey wearing a top hat
it's a pilgrim's hat where's the buckle
santiago
so i will attend your dinner cool
yeah don't worry about it either way
it's not a big deal
[Music]
i'm gonna give a toast tell him how
thankful i am to have him in the
precinct
and officially ask him to be my mentor
wait are you only hosting dinner because
you want to suck up the halt you said
you were only coming to see if my
apartment was the reason i was single or
if it was my personality like you
suspected
same to you your honor oh what judge
were you talking to
that was my mother you call your mom
your honor she's a federal judge in the
ninth circuit
what else would i call her okay
nothing all open cases are assigned come
on there's got to be something i can
investigate all right well when there's
nothing there's nothing you know
don't worry sir i will stay here all
night figuring this out
you want an excuse to skip santiago's
thanksgiving dinner because for some
reason you refuse to celebrate this
holiday like a normal person i want to
do what i do every year sit at home
watch football and eat mayonnut
spoonsies
those are spoonfuls of mayo sprinkled
with peanuts that's revolting maybe so
but it's what i invented when i was six
because my mom was working so i had to
make dinner for myself
my sad story trumps your insult jake
if a case opens up it's yours but if not
you will be at santiago's as a
professional courtesy well i gotta say
it's not as bad as i thought it would be
oh look at that depression glass i have
to practice my toast
god how long is that eight pages
single-spaced double-sided
santiago-style
my body is starting to digest itself no
eating until the captain gets here
i'd rather spend thanksgiving at your
house than with my sister
things you find at the beach for us i
had seagulls good one diana
ice cream break yay the holt at your
house surrounded by these idiots
guaranteed train wreck
thanks for the invite he's here okay
he's here everybody
be cool why do you have your shirt off i
can't spill food on your shirt you're
not wearing one
i am thankful that thanksgiving only
comes once a year
people stuff themselves and then at
midnight they run to appliance stores
and trample each other to death
when i was a little girl playing cops
and robbers with my brothers
oh no please continue santiago no
someone sold ten thousand dollars from
the evidence logo yes oh
awesome why is that awesome it's a case
you said i could hop on any case that
came up
it's a thanksgiving miracle password
fast forward wait
wait stop stop stop okay so here's our
money
fast forward hold it hold it go back
there's our guy got him okay we should
start by checking all the perps that
were released from holding today
good idea and if it's none of them we
may miss santiago's altogether
thanksgiving is dead
i'm eating
[Music]
what didn't eat potatoes butter a little
milk
and i ran out of salt so i used baking
soda
baking soda i need a little bit of
baking soda but
even if it is one of them how would we
know easy the guy in the footage was
left-handed
we just give all of our suspects some
made-up form to sign and see which hand
they use
punch it good did that
now punch it safety first
punch it okay see now i just feel like
you're missing
amy the toilet's overflowing what
ew scully what did you do and the night
gets worse better
i didn't do it well then who clogged it
oh terry you said you ate the whole
turkey
toilet
you all ate those brownies i brought in
last week i thought they were erasers
yeah thanksgiving's over i i'm not done
hanging out let's go to the bar there's
your food there that's a great idea
oh look at that boyle saves thanksgiving
does it really say that
no but it does say boyle believes
obvious lie damn it
oh rooting for you buddy i'll play
detective bart barley
tightly wound hates violence against
animals and you're my partner
gerald jime but one
the murder of his wife we're all to take
this seriously
i am as seriously as you're taking the
search for the man who killed jane jimes
your only clue he wore a yellow sweater
you're considering it let's get in there
nypd what's going on right in the middle
of carbon turkey i'm vegetarian
eating meat is murder i hate violence
against animals
we overlooked uh release formulas both
every time we apologize
yeah he's right-handed let's go what do
you guys want
sorry to bother you sir my partner here
forgot about a form we needed you to
sign what's happening donnie what'd you
do
i didn't do anything what did donny do i
don't know what this is about why won't
you ever believe me
cause i raised a liar shut up mom hey
i'll talk to mom like that don't you
tell me what to do louie excuse me
not the rules
my wife was murdered by a man in a
yellow sweater yes
it's the one case i can't solve
don't fight with family don't fight with
family
sign this that's a hell of a
breakthrough james
i'm proud of you we just caught our man
he signed with his right hand that's
right he did but he didn't do it
he did what canal but notice you throw
in those rolls with your left hand boss
not to mention this hoodie matches our
security footage exactly
you stole that money when you came in to
pick up your brother from holding today
didn't you
damn it so where's the money now it's
not here all right i bet it all in the
football game my bookie has it
yes the case continues this is not good
sorry jimes his father was murdered by a
bookie
our purp says that bookie operates out
of a hidden back room ten dollars to
play
oh we're just looking around forty
dollars just to look around
all right we'll play 15 to play
great
[Laughter]
hey rough night yeah
certainly hasn't gone according to plan
oh no oh amy i was ordering a drink
called a rough night
it's tequila with a nicotine patch oh
gross how do i get hole to pay attention
to me sure spends a lot of time on
peralta
i should start screwing up like jake
does i can act out too you know
please do
ow all of you i think i'm getting the
hang of this these tiles are either game
pieces or
i think candy just won the guy by the
bathroom seems very interested in the
commotion you just made
yeah andy's been waiting for the toilet
since we got here ten to one that's not
a bathroom and he's a lookout
let's go yeah did he arrest the other
guy what they didn't arrest the other
guy
no i guess not they'll come back for him
later
once they find the money are you eating
packing peanuts
i do keep the secret stash of food in
the office i knew it
where is there the one with the water
stain there's a lot of food up there
yeah it's a smorgasbord
it's over thanksgiving time of death now
no
this will not be our thanksgiving all
right you all wait here give me an hour
terry to the door i'm just gonna put you
down man
yeah totally that makes sense that makes
sense
never mind let's go what it's really a
bathroom no no no there's tons of
illegal stuff happening in there
but they're watching the football game
and i deviated i don't want to see the
score
okay fine we'll go get the stolen money
put it down put it down this is a weird
request phil will you switch places with
me i really don't want to see the score
oh yeah thank you that's so much better
oh why are there so many tvs in here
[Laughter]
this is hilarious what's your problem
with celebrating thanksgiving
it's a sucky holiday it's always sucked
my mom worked my dad was gone and i sat
at home watching football
i came from a very formal family my
parents were not especially affectionate
really your honor wasn't a big snuggler
well that's nice captain but i don't
have a new family yet
so i guess i'm stuck with my awesome old
tradition what are you all doing here
amy broke everything and got us kicked
out of the bar then we got attacked by
rats
it's the best thanksgiving ever happy
turkey day
right through there gentlemen not a lot
of places are open so this will be a
multi-ethnic non-traditional
thanksgiving it's a real culinary
challenge
give me 15 minutes and then we feast
make it five can you eat with your eyes
so the plating alone
hey boyle just spent a lot of money yeah
absolutely
captain i want to tell you something
forget it the moment's passed
is this about your toast ah
gina gave it to me very well written
there are several compelling anecdotes
the fonts suit the tone
i do feel however the word choice could
have been improved in spots i mark them
awk for awkward that's the best thing
anyone's ever
said to me i marked them awk for awkward
he's mentoring me
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm here i'm here oh hey oh
suited up what are you wearing santiago
said to dress up so
well you look beautiful that's my thing
now i'm just owning it
hey thanks for giving a copy of my toast
to holt that was nice of you
oh to be honest i kind of gave it to him
as a prank
because i thought it would be super
embarrassing for you
of course of course
excuse me uh so earlier at amy's i
didn't give a
real toast because i didn't know what to
say
but since that time a wise
unsmiling man named gerald jimes made me
realize what i am thankful for
so i just like to say i am happy to be
here
with my family with two black dads
two latina daughters and two white sons
gina and i don't know what you are
some strange giant baby
[Applause]
that was perfect that was a perfect
episode feels so good right now
it's a perfect episode it feels so good
oh good and warm
ah perfect
no i'm crying
that's that's good that was perfect this
is perfect that's
perfect i don't know there's like
literally
is amazing in every every avenue
of it yeah absolutely ah so perfect
i feel so warm and fits it's perfect
because it's like it's a hilarious
episode anyway but it also has all the
sort of like heart swell you want out of
some kind of holiday episode without
sacrificing any of the kind of
humor you come to this show you know
i think the only thing that if i have
one
tiny tiny nitpick just because i feel
like it
sounds like i i feel like i gotta say
something for some reason when i really
i don't
you have to please bring some rain to
this parade
um pick that knit i didn't find the
terry
food bit as funny as much focus
as there was put toward it yes yeah
that's about it
i feel like it could have grown as a bit
and it didn't really progress beyond
one note of the joke that was that was
about it
i mean the thing with the rats and stuff
was a really funny moment
that was that was a hilarious ass moment
but
other than that literally everything was
just firing on all cylinders and like
every single department although
terry ate the baking soda that's pretty
funny yeah
well i mean him just unloading his
entire refrigerator onto oil in the
first part of the episode like there are
definitely charming moments yeah
yeah um but oh
god i'm just so i'm just so swelling
with emotion i don't have a
singular clear thought here i i i
really thought that um as predictable as
the arc would be
with andy samberg coming around and
realizing who his real family is
it was it was just executed so well on
such a hilarious journey because he's in
such like avoidance
the entire time and like the whole thing
when he's out investigating
with it was just fun to get like a true
investigative detective episode as a b
story with uh peralta and holt
and watch them actually go out on the
field together and really investigate
and the whole thing about like the
make-believe and then the
like that whole make-believe bit was
hilarious for just right from the start
it was so
funny that was this dude where were we
cutting the turkey against that
piece like just right in front and then
when hold
just declares my wife was killed by the
man and the yellow
i've never really insulted so funny
you should appreciate your family oh
that was so funny it's such a
spontaneous but like like
it's unexpected of his character yeah
because you do
expect him to maybe lay down the law but
absolutely not to commit to the bit
yeah it's so wonderful and two like it
makes sense just because it's like a
family squabble he's witnessing right in
front of him
yeah it made sense that he resorted to
it it's just the last thing you'd expect
for him to ever pl play along or use
that as any resort yeah absolutely it's
a
great unexpected moment but like the
littlest thing every
every joke here most like 99
most of the episodes have like okay it
takes a few minutes all right now it's
like you really entered in
but from like the very start oh bingo
man the boyle bingo bill was super funny
and i love how he kept coming back
around
yeah um oh yeah this is this episode
like recurring gags galore
that was not stopped right from like the
football game i kind of loved how he was
trying to avoid the football scores i
think it's because
um for certain things that you know we
really care about we we try to avoid
spoilers on them there are some things
where we're like i don't really give a
[ __ ] but then uh
but there are some things like please
don't spoil this for me like
um yeah so like flip
mood knobs and you can relate to
something like yeah childish as yeah
they're playing the thing that you've
been saving for just the right occasion
in the next room where we have to go do
this bust they know their characters so
well like how rosa's
loving how shitty everything's going is
the lining in it but
even right when she says you had to go
ruin it by having me the best
thanksgiving at dinner i've ever had
yeah you know that she's appreciative
what a great way for her to come around
without having her say it
yeah yeah absolutely like boyle's plan
worked and boyle saved thanksgiving
yeah boyle literally he's safe he really
goes to the occasion that he did not
let himself be flapped by the meme of
his own
enthusiast that's what i mean it's
bookended by that now like we make fun
of how boyle is about thanksgiving and
how important and
how special it has to be and then in the
end he's really the hero
for it all yeah absolutely special and
i'm sorry
and i mean poor santiago just because
like you know
everybody like ripping apart her
apartment and whatnot and
just like i also like that too where
yeah it's like you get the cop b
story but you also get like a very home
life kind of reveal on her at least
well she yeah she's a very she's an old
old lady at heart yeah
um but yeah with her uh
wanting the mentor and
like the thing about like character
motivations
is it's like
when you talk about stakes within the
character's goal
what matters is how important that goal
is to that person
and if you can sell the audience on that
that's where the tension is run out of
that's where the
stakes are felt so like when it comes
time for her speech and then he's
interrupting
you feel that and you're like i have to
go leave like you feel that because
you know and like if you're like
pitching that as a plot like this this
woman really wants to give a speech and
to have her captain mentor her but it's
interrupted by uh
by a phone call at the police station
has to go that doesn't sound like a big
deal
but the show does such a great job with
her and she does such a great
performance yeah
that you know that this is life or death
for her
yeah that's like the the pinnacle of
things going wrong today
like the final kicker into this being
the worst thanksgiving possible
she needed it to be perfect and i love
how uh yeah he reads her speech at the
end and ultimately does start mentoring
her like it's such a sweet moment
yeah and gina this is the funniest she's
ever been
this whole time we've been watching it
she was hilarious here
well i love the joke about that i
brought brownies i thought that's her
erasers
she's such a funny line well she i love
the way that her character seems to
exist in this weird venn diagram of like
yeah like like it's summed up in the end
to me when she's like
originally i was happy because i thought
this was going terribly but i guess in a
way i'm kind of happy that it went okay
yeah i am happy yeah because you think
gina oh she really
has a heart and she tried to do
something good but she was just trying
to embarrass her
accident but it was good yeah that is so
funny
like there's this brilliant comedy in
this one yeah and
it really does get you in the feels by
the end absolutely
i mean it's funny because like uh yorma
taconi directed this and he's the third
of the lonely island and it's
really yeah yeah yeah it certainly had
like especially too just in the rhythm
and the pace you know a lot of that
energy
yeah this was captured great yeah i i
was so
oh dude so dazzled by this episode the
one chase down sequence with the whole
like you know car chase and he's like
running after the guy and it's like the
really high shutter speed it's all like
clippy looking
oh brilliantly edited with that
punchline yeah they're just getting into
traffic yeah
immediately behind the dump truck
because that is something i've thought
about
of like car chases and like these guys
never like
immediately hit traffic if you get into
car chase in los angeles at like 5 p.m
no chance you're gonna get the odds
not in your favor but especially in new
york city too oh
anywhere
i'd hate to drive i don't like that's
actually a big fear of mine is ever
driving in new york city
getaway drivers are paid the most out of
any heist squad in new york
um and yeah i like the bits when they
really allow new york to feel lived in
it's like it's funny how no one at the
precinct has like a thick new york
accent
i know it was a common trope in new york
shows yeah even friends had it
like they matt leblanc used to do a
little bit more of a new york accent and
just like went away yeah
um but knowing that the precinct has it
when they encounter other people they'll
have like
whatever yeah yeah well yeah like that
that whole house they stop in on is like
the most new yorky new york accent like
family squabble stereotype possible
yeah this is wonderful this was uh this
is an amazi this is
like beginning to end it was almost
pitched it was like
almost perfect like so close to being a
perfect episode
yeah um yeah i i adored this one a lot
like every everyone was great yeah it's
it's weird all i can just keep saying is
saying different all i'm doing is just
repeating myself
just saying it's great it's so great
it's me this whole time talking about
yeah you get your your you know
character comedy like you come to expect
you know you get the madcap rapid fire
jokes but you also get what feels like
some very
just genuine character beats within that
you know it's really well done
really beautifully done well they pay
attention to such great
detail on on how to make certain things
even funnier like even when
terry throws the turkey in the toilet
when he's the last one and he's like
stepping on it and he's just like
looking out
like what a ridiculous gag he's just
stuffing a turkey and the toilet is
so stupid it's so dumb never gonna fit
in there everyone's resorting to
throwing food in the toilet it's
hilarious
there's a funny ass like this was um
this this is a great
it's like a sketch i like when they go
into like sketch comedy territory but
not
breaking the realm of that you're still
a sitcom yeah it's like they really grip
the characters and they really motivate
a lot with the characters but they also
just incorporate like
silly gaggery to a degree yeah like it's
there's a certain silliness baked within
all the characters that somehow holds
the more ridiculous stuff together you
know there was like a
bit of a lethal weapon vibe about having
hult and peralta
out there taking on the chinese people
yeah maybe jet li will show up because
the weapon four no yeah
jet league going all right guys
well what did you love about this
episode
leave your thoughts down below who i had
uh
that that was that was brilliant hey
subscribe click bells hit like buttons
get potty trained coffee
step up get some trade go to go to the
link in the in the description and get
that
coffee drinktrade.com oh patreon
who you got john i got robert gunderson
because if there's anyone in our patreon
who sounds like a cold
hardened cop it's robert gunderson
i could see you now on the beat
resistant to having a partner but then
they give you a crazy new experimental
robot sidekick or something
gunderson and the droid
isn't that be cool and then they can
solve grimes together
in some kind of not too distant future
where like robots have started to break
the prime directive and hurt people and
like oh that's not supposed to happen
who can solve it
gundersen and the droids
plus you know you would be stalked on
cars you're that guy in the writer's
room huh
yeah i write best alone
and then occasionally i'll send you the
script
after i've come down from like a
mountaintop
where it's alone enough that i can hear
myself think without judgment
and you are the benefactor of that today
robert gunderson because this is gonna
be my
uh this is gonna be our claim to fame
we're gonna
get this thing sold man then your life
is going to be
public stories
thank you robert gundrenster for being
part of our patreon page you mean a lot
yeah and whatever john
said value i hope you had fun